writing style versus voice mm-hmm what
are the differences yeah why always
possible I always talk what is the
difference between character and voice
so a character is someone in a story and
they're going to have a voice which is
going to be a way that they talk but
then the overarching voice of a story is
you know more about the way that it's
told like the style and the voice in
terms of the writing and sometimes that
is also the character's voice especially
if you're writing in first person or
third person clothes because you're
trying to encapsulate what they see and
feel and then what was the other thing
you asked about oh you're in style yeah
they kind of overlap a little bit I mean
the style of writing and the voice voice
is really trying to capture the feeling
of the the narrator's voice or the
character's voice or the way the story
is told the style of it I guess would be
more like the way that you're writing
the book but there's a lot of overlap
between all three of those areas but
when you pick up a book that has really
strong voice you know you're usually
hearing the character and hearing the
world and every book exists within its
own world even books that aren't
specifically sci-fi/fantasy
you're still crafting a world even if
it's something like a thriller it has a
feel and an internal logic to the world
and it's not necessarily the real world
even if it is a contemporary story
something like bonds or all exists in
its own world I don't think those people
exist in the real world those characters
to me are very unrealistic and a lot of
respects but in the world of that story
they're all like that and so I don't
think that that's like a real world
thing even though it takes place here
and now but there is a specific way that
she writes her stories and that you know
she transports you into them I'm hooking
in the reader from the beginning how is
I'm sure going to vary especially within
the why a world and the different genres
that there are whether it's fiction
whether its steampunk whatever yeah a
steampunk Oh fun yeah I mean I think
hooking the reader is just so important
and regardless of what you're writing I
just think you know for me if I'm not
really feeling a buck-fifty and I don't
put a lot of books down but 1500 pages
is a long time
and if I'm not feeling it and you'd be
surprised how many books I think don't
really work on that level I may not
finish it and especially when you're
dealing with more commercial genres it
becomes even more important younger
readers I think it becomes even more
important that said I don't think you
need to rush or sacrifice the
storytelling to make it so hooky in a
certain respect like I personally
wouldn't want to do that but I think
getting into the story right away having
something exciting happen in the
beginning in my book I chose to write a
prologue that showed kind of what
happened before when the surface of the
earth was destroyed so I told it from if
you can imagine the president's
daughters point of view as they're
evacuating the White House so young girl
being evacuated and I because I did that
and for a couple reasons but one was I
wanted have something really exciting
and really relatable that happened right
off the bat because I think that that
will cook you in and make you want to
read more but there's other ways to hook
somebody you're like having a great
character having central mystery is
something I teach about a lot which is
it doesn't mean that it has to obviously
there's a mystery genre where the whole
story is crafted around a mystery but
that said you can have a story that has
smaller mysteries that are revealed in
the beginning of a book a good example
is in The Hunger Games they talked about
the reaping which is the big thing
happens right away in the Hunger Games
but they say the word the reaping seven
or eight times before they finally tell
you what it is and you find out fairly
early in the story but still you're kind
of reading like oh what is this what is
this thing that's happening what is this
big event so I think that's another way
to kind of get somebody interested and
trying to figure out what's going on too
much conflict too little conflict do ye
readers want more conflict than maybe
adult readers I think then you have more
leeway to do some bigger kind of more
epic sweeping sorts of things like what
you would see in a Star Wars movie for
example you know too little conflict in
any story or too little tension and the
story is going to be really boring and
nobody's going to be interested I think
you need to have conflict and tension
almost if not in every scene of your
book pretty much in every scene even
scenes that are character-driven I
always think you want to look for how
can you ramp up the tension in that even
if it's just a dialogue exchange you try
to have moments that are ratcheting up
the tension so a good example of that is
something like in the beginning of the
shining the movie I also love the book
with the film there's a scene where it's
the mom talking to Child Protective
Services so you're learning information
about the fact that the father may have
been abusive towards the Sun but it's
just a dialogue scene but the whole time
she's smoking a cigarette and the ash
just gets longer and longer and you're
like oh my god ash your cigarette you
get so tense for her you're like that's
going to fall all over you and she
doesn't and it just somehow is this
genius way of just keeping tension so
there's always little things you can
look at in a scene to kind of keep the
tension going and then obviously there's
big conflict scenes where there's a
fight or actually something major
happening or a major obstacle but I
think throughout a story that's what
keeps you reading and people would be
like oh it's getting worse it's getting
so much worse for these characters and
you know or even like a book series like
Game of Thrones you're like oh my god
things are still happening and happening
but it's like that's what keeps the
story going you know a story about
conflict is a really boring story
I think Kurt Vonnegut famously said make
great characters and then make bad
things happen to them well if the book
is not part of a series let's suppose
it's just going to be a standalone book
is the protagonist always victorious in
the end no and I think you've been in a
and you see that a lot especially on my
books considered just hope Ian you see
that a lot in dystopian series where a
lot of times they're not victorious and
I always let me teach structure I talk
about that where you know there's going
to be a moment at the end of a story
where a character makes a decision they
need to make a choice that really
reveals their moral caliber but that
doesn't mean as a choice they make have
to be the right one
a good example is Romeo and Juliet right
Romeo does make a choice at the end and
it is a terrible choice and tragically
for him he made the wrong decision so
know it doesn't always have to result in
a happy ending and I think some of the
greatest stories
times don't that said I think if you are
going to go for a really kind of recalls
a negative ending but an ending where
the protagonist is not victorious it
makes your job so much harder in a lot
of ways I think you really need to pull
that off because your readers are
probably going to be a little bit mad at
you to a certain extent so I think it
needs to have a compelling reason to
have that sort of ending or you know a
compelling reason why you wanted to do
that for your story because we've all
been there always seen something with it
with an ending that we were like oh wow
that was really dark and like sometimes
I love it even in films where you know
classically a lot of that is focus group
tested out of the film but sounds like I
am Legend or the 3rd Terminator film
where like something really dark happens
at the end but then it's awesome and of
course if you get into more like horror
movies and things like that then it's
almost expected because a lot of times
in those the antagonists becomes the
protagonist so when we're watching
nightmare down straight right ok
originally yeah maybe we're rooting for
Johnny Depp and the teams but the
certain point Freddy is the who we're
rooting for at a certain point you're
showing up at these films to see Michael
Myers or you know Leatherface or whoever
pinhead I'm a huge Hellraiser fan but
you're showing up for them more so
almost then who are the classic
protagonists and you kind of want to see
them when in the end and boy would you
be upset if Freddy was dead at the end I
know Freddy's dead as a movie but not
really does